I love Stefan but I always feel bad cuz
I don't I've never done it without
breaking because John will put in
different things or he'll tell me as I'm
walking out and it's just like throwing
stuff at me and when I hosted last John
came out is and and he I thought he was
gonna do it kind of like and the Stefan
boys like hey Stefan or what he was
hello Stefan lupus
and he just must visit my ear my
girlfriend works at Yoshinoya beef ball
so he's he's alive and he's seeing jokes
he's never seen before for the first
time well just so that he wouldn't trip
up over the wording is if you read a cue
card you wouldn't might not understand
it but I'll go up to him and I'll be
like there's a new club owner and it's
Bologna Danza it's that saying of when
you put a [ __ ] on his cable I started
changing the lines before he would go
out there just a little not all the
lines but just think a little bit like
I'd throw in like three screaming babies
and go sideways there's a detail and he
wouldn't have seen actually went out
there screaming babies and Mozart with
was there okay I'm gonna be like a dumb
person how much of I like some of that
checks there phone yeah do it oh you
know what dude dude Bill Clinton
[Applause]
come up with something do something I
mean just do I mean do it no don't do
dogs at low rent don't do stuff about
the personal stuff that's low-class the
a stepping back a decade right just John
one time we were just sitting there
trying to write and we were in a
restaurant and we were looking over and
there's a guy talking to his son very
sternly and John went your mother and I
are separating
[Laughter]
have you heard of Blacula the black
dracula yes well they have a Jewish
Dracula Oh what's his name Sidney
Applebaum
[Laughter]